I told you that I want to go to that festival in Sweden.
No, you said it would be cool to go.
Yeah, and then I got the opportunity and I decided to do.
Look, I don't mind you going.
I just wished you would've told me, that's all.
Dude, she needs a therapist.
You've been wanting out of
this stupid relationship for like a year now.
And don't forget about all of
the beautiful Swedish women you'll meet in June.
Okay, guys.
That's not her again, seriously?
Babe, what's happening?
Dani?
I was so very sorry to hear about what happened.
I'm sorry.
I invited Dani to come to Sweden.
You know what she's been going through.
Christian says you've got this special week planned.
It's sort of a crazy festival.
Special ceremonies and dressing up.
That sounds fun.
Unbelievable.
Welcome and happy midsommar!
Skål!
What time is it?
9 p.m.
That can't be right, the sky is blue.
This is what 9 p.m. Is like here.
How long have you two been together?
Just over three and a half years.
Four years.
Really?
Yeah.
What do you think?
It's like another world.
Tomorrow's a big day.
Is it scary?
What is it?
It has special properties.
What am I going through?
We just need to acclimate.
I don't want to acclimate, I wanna go.
Absolutely not.
What's happening?
I don't know why you invited us.
That's why you look so guilty right now
because you know.
We only do this every 90 years.
I was most excited for you to come.